to get a better idea of how the
coronavirus is having an impact on
communities closer to the epicenter in
Wuhan and Hubei Province
we took a southbound train from Beijing
we got off in central Hunan province its
southern border with who Bay covers more
than 400 kilometers the longest of any
other province and the spreading of the
virus is a big and sensitive concern as
we're about to exit the station we were
met by a local government official he
knew we were coming and told the local
police our planned this new trying to go
to China Yan I told them the calm pasta
checkpoint they have to go back to
Beijing but they said they wouldn't stop
us instead they would follow us until we
reach the checkpoint to the community we
wanted to visit the sign says all the
cars to stop for check we're about an
hour away from the train station that
chong guang exit from the freeway this
is described as the medical supply
capital of China so we wanted to go in
because the face masks are manufactured
there more than 50% for China are
manufactured inside and we've heard that
they've brought the staff back from
their holiday early to manufacture more
face masks but it's so sensitive they're
stopping us here not even letting us go
inside we were not the only ones being
turned away other cars were prevented
from going in if they could not prove
that they were from Chong yang and then
we were told by the official that if we
did not leave Hunan Province before the
end of the day it was highly likely that
we would be put in quarantine as the end
of the extended holiday draws closer
many people in these communities could
be cut off even longer if additional
transportation restrictions are put into
place Scott Haller al-jazeera chung-yong